let's start off with the first category
that of course uh being
the best intro best intro wow just the
two that's the two
we asked ashley to put uh these like tag
lines for each of the ones as well which
i'm seeing for the first time
i didn't realize we asked him to do that
that's the first i've heard about this
what is
the best intro nominations you're
probably wondering well here they are
um let's find out oh
god no actually you spoiled the winner
all right so the first one is the salty
salmon slices from episode four i don't
remember this one
this is the first one that i did which
is different okay okay let's listen to
this one
what's up you salty salmon slices
welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste podcast
i'm sorry you know how old it is when
you see how long my hair is
in that oh yeah because this was before
you got the haircut before i got the
haircut i
remember you didn't did you i don't
think you told us that you're just going
to do a random introduction i think
that's how started yeah
i was like i'm sure those dumb intros
begin from this point yeah exactly
i mean i think that's where they started
yeah yeah yeah because most of these are
just most of these are mine
yeah yeah and episode 14 there's
what's up you delicious [ __ ] sorry
welcome back to another episode of trash
day
did you say you delicious [ __ ] yeah
i don't remember any of this i don't
remember this either um then we got
uh new people pp nation
nation
that's after the coup d'etat okay of
course of course of course what's up big
pb nation
welcome back to another episode i
couldn't
i tried to say it with a straight face
i'm sorry i love how joey
laughs to himself about the dumb [ __ ]
that he says
because like no i laughed at that one
because i was like oh this was
ten times funnier in my head the moment
i said out loud
saying 69 yeah yeah the moment i said it
out loud i was like this isn't funny
but it made it on here somehow and then
apparently we have episode 40 43 and 44
so we had like three apparently
banger intro yeah wow about that so this
is the crazy comedy i wasn't very happy
because i was like good job you're gonna
get to monetize i think this episode
this is the monitor
probably so don't say it bleep it man
yeah what's that big crazy corn beanie
that wasn't my idea that was gone yeah
that's right it wasn't my idea god told
me to say it
why would you believe him if john told
you to put your hand in the fire would
you do it
god like quietly was like you should say
this at the beginning i don't know what
you're talking about
then joey's like john travolta meme
looking around the room why is it
demolition
why is it youtube come on and then we
got episode 43 connor shits on his phone
i don't know i can already tell this is
not me
so this is this is connor intro i
actually watched my phone like
once once a week i don't like you it
gets like [ __ ] on it i don't really like
it
i [ __ ] on my phone melee i don't
remember that
i don't remember that either i don't
remember that like that was like
five five six weeks ago [ __ ] yeah
right i don't remember saying that
and then we got the final one episode 44
uh ladybug
i remember this one i remember this one
i don't know out of every intro this was
the only one i remember this is the
weirdest injury by far
play the clip all right we're live in
five
four three
hello everyone i love the edit on this
how it just slowly fades into yeah
well it's slowly going live i don't
remember this at all
to be fair the entire ladybird episode
is a fever dream to me
it it is like i don't know how you
handled sitting next to him right
i did like did you see how quiet i
wanted that episode
i didn't handle it like i i i just
remember the ladybird episode because
they just took me back so much
about how much energy was just radiating
for the guy yeah
it was that episode where i was like oh
we we really must be like low energy
on our episodes yeah well either that or
this guy i think i think we have an
appropriate amount of energy i
think i think ladybird has far too much
energy
for any one human being to have yeah
yeah yeah yeah you just you just i feel
like maybe he's siphoning everyone
else's energy yeah it could just feel
like tired around here yeah yeah
how do you do this this is impressive so
uh which one do you think is the winner
guys well let's let's let's give our uh
i mean
i mean i mean let's let's pretend that
we did it actually
let's just talk about our favorite one
yeah what's your favorite one um
i honestly don't have a horse in this
race this isn't a category that i feel
too passionate about
i'm gonna be honest with you guys this
is one that i might you know i don't
really mind who wins this one yeah
a lot i'm in most of these horses yeah
yeah yeah so what's your opinion joey
yeah but the thing is i'm most of these
horses and yet i
don't really care either oh all of my
interest is just as dumb as the next
true true oh i'm like five so i'm like
big pp nation hilarious
yeah that's i hope that one works yeah i
hope big peepee nation or
salty salmon slices just because it
started the tradition but uh
ladybird i guess i don't know that's
just weird it was like a fifa dream
all right do you want to know the cards
right here who won joey
all right and then
[Music]
we are 10 year olds this is epic
how what was the percentage that it won
by do we know
how many viewers did it get of x amount
i'm trying to bring up the stacks now
i'm glad that we can confirm it gives
you a pie chart though yeah yeah
it's loading i think there's just too
many responses i'm glad that we can
confirm that our audience are as
just mentally young as we are yeah as
mentally young as i am yeah
everyone's just immature which i which
is guess what which is why i guess
everyone loves talking about [ __ ] here
i wonder if it's a case of like people
didn't really feel that strongly about
any particular intro and it had the
funniest name i wonder
what yeah if i saw this i think i would
see you know salty salmon slices i sleep
peepee nation
okay yeah okay okay can i just can i
just say
opening this up feels so good oh i'm
just
looking forward to my turn again
actually did these for us
yeah it looks so nice that looks so good
shall we go to the next awards then yeah
what is what is the next one let's go to
the next one yeah yeah
what are the stats uh it won with 22.6
percent of the vote with 22.6 percent of
the votes
what was the next one what was the
closest one closest one was uh ladybird
of course 21.8 percent oh wow that was
that's that's what
was different one percent difference
it's about 200 votes about 200 wow
big pb nation won by 200 rise up nation
rise up confirmed the only thing that
can be ladybird is big ppb
nation what's the difference
he's the leader of the beginning